the the big thing panzer of course is
fan art and sarah pascua i know you have
had that accolade of people sending you
fan art i mean yeah so i've got one
piece and i think fan art is a strong
word
um yes okay
so
it's actually it's worth saying that
it's all of you
it is this is the the fan art of sarah
pascal
now the reason i think fan art is a very
loose term is i was given this at a gig
in lieu of payment
don't brag about my career
but that's because the guy who ran the
gig had spent too much at the bar
to pay me so he painted that yes
after being at the bar
what are those bits i just think they're
just free
biscuits
donuts or something
you can send
pictures of people who tattooed your
face on their bikes oh no i'm not there
yet
have you have you got yeah one day
i get them in my twitter feed all the
times guys who have whole calves the
calves or a picture of jewels on their
chest or
wow nick fury
people love the event and now tom
middleton you have found out but such
specific fan art this is a lot yeah does
it all come from this one scene it was
it the first thor movie with the spear
right right yeah yes um there's a
there's a scene in a first thor film
where my i'm trying to attack
thor chris hemsworth as thor with a
spear
and i jump in the air and he dodges out
the way and i
bring the spear down and it wedges
itself into the floor and then i use the
use it to spin myself around and kick
him in the chest
which has been interpreted by fans as
a demonstration of my hidden talent at
pole dance pole dancer
yeah no actually there's so much of this
but this is just one example of loki
really going for it on the pole
is that japanese and that's what you
wear in the movie yeah
have you not seen it yeah that's loki's
oh really we'll print it out you can
take it home
wow uh moonlight and the oscars it is
now kind of stuff of legends the the end
when they write out the wrong name and
we've talked about it on the show before
and warren beatty's been here we asked
him what would have done everything um
but you were in the middle of it so you
did end up on stage you did go up in the
end eventually yeah i mean yeah it took
me a while because i was kind of glued
to my seat in just shock and then our
producer dragged me on stage so but is
it a nice way to win to have
disappointment first and then go oh no
yay
i think it is in a way because there's
never been a moment like that before all
since at the oscars so
i think it's kind of cool and whenever i
always remember that moment everyone
remember well when you're on stage you
were looking out at the audience and
we've shown this picture before it's a
great picture it's everyone
like matt heyman like a fly could find
me
shell wouldn't look shocked but i don't
think anyone is quite as concerned
you seem really really taken by i really
was i and i remember yeah
like meryl seems less bothered than you
do
meryl is composed i i honestly thought i
i'm seconds away from running up on the
stage and kicking somebody's ass because
i thought
some [__] was going down so that's
what i thought you know i thought like
we were in the middle of like somebody
trying to hijack
something yeah and now and then i knew
she had already said yes by the way to
rampage so she was on stage i was like
you don't mess with my girl
that's my girl
fantastic this i find unbelievable that
jason when you were filming with
jennifer you did not spot her jewelry in
this scene you didn't know who here
knows what that is oliver's uh is it a
[__] green
no i've actually been like honestly yeah
is it really that's what that is coke
no one here knew that right so
no one here knew that did anyone know
that no no no that's a good answer
did anyone smell it during the day yes
they did that well not everybody else
kept saying that's a really nice
necklace that's gorgeous and siddakis of
course walks right up to me and he goes
is that a [__] ring
and i said really well you've just given
me some insight into your sweet personal
life yeah
all i knew what it was too
it's
so embarrassed right now
oh poor ollie yeah i know why'd you do
this to me
i guess no one told you life is going to
be this way
[Applause]
we've been here since five o'clock
rehearsal
has just been you guys have been
rehearsed
that's adorable that was really good do
that again
so i guess no one told you life is going
to be this way
so actually so here's the game now i'm
not going to say it again but if anyone
else wants to feed it into conversation
don't let me down
you did really good so far
don't spoil it what is the line again oh
uh no one ever told you life's gonna be
i look like look at me i'm trying to
remember it
i told you so my life was gonna be this
way
you guys are good
[Music]
you do this all night
i'm going to wear dame judy dench out on
that
ring on one of the things i found really
moving in the book was the way
you
paid tribute to the achievements of your
children was it sam who helped you with
a bit of online trolling
with the virtual
world uh within the whole online thing
so my daughter see my instagram they're
doing my instagram posts and my son is
there to kind of troubleshoot for me and
uh very early on and i was i was my
daughter explained to me what fomo meant
because that was my whole life i was
fear of missing out because i couldn't
catch up with everybody
and uh so i i i she taught me that but
then i got in trouble on twitter
somebody who said something nasty about
parkinson's and i usually let that stuff
just go by me it doesn't happen that
often when it does that don't really
care about it but i just i wanted to
answer this guy in some way so my son
said
just do this do smh
and i said why don't he ask me just just
trust me do smh so i answer the guy back
smh and he answered me back that's the
funniest thing i've ever read in my life
you're the king of the internet i
apologize for anything i said to you
blah blah blah and i said to my son what
the [__] did you say
and he said shaking my head
i mean you don't have to go far on the
interweb to find uh quite extreme
reactions to that scene but you know
shirt on here's what somebody tell
michael b jordan that my ovaries are
ready for michael c jordan
[Applause]
there's more there's a lot more here's
another one does michael b jordan make
anyone else want to rip their lungs out
that doesn't seem an erotic reaction
that's creative that's so creative you
are so sexy i'm gonna eat my lungs
i would sell three toes and one kidney
to be in the same room
is there a market for toast
yes but uh yeah i don't this is sweet
right so the fans because the fans who
go to do it they then of course want to
blog about it because they've had this
amazing experience but when they blog
about it it's borderline confusing on
whether they had a good time or not so
here are some of the blog things
so we were asked to go to the living
room sit down not know how much i was
sweating during that moment i was like
the [__] is gonna happen
i could not keep up then all of a sudden
she just pops up out of nowhere she
appeared out of thin air like david
copperfield and we all died like for
real
wait there's more
this one
so she said she'll be playing her album
first let me tell you the noise that
came out of my mouth was not human
i legit almost told mama swift to call
me an ambulance because i wasn't gonna
make it
[Applause]
i love them so much because they always
talk about dying
you're like rest in peace me all right
me
i died dead
we took a little break we did a little
break as she was passing around rice
crispy treats and cookies and i was
talking to her mom for a little and then
i walked back in and she was like hey
babe thanks for coming do you want a
treat and i was like i would but i think
i'm dead
[Applause]
this one oh this is brilliant mid
sentence she stopped talking and pointed
to amanda and said amanda i'm so glad
you're here amanda died right there
[Applause]
and finally finally uh guys just wait
for the one she did with imogen heap
because damn that one slayed everyone to
heaven and back while listening to the
song i literally had to plan my funeral
arrangements
so yeah when i was um
17 maybe 18 uh i went for a hand
modelling job i thought it's all right
i'm only five foot one they i don't this
this doesn't work for modeling but hands
i can do beautiful hair beautiful plans
i can do went into a room full of very
it was a very white room it was a very
english room walked in i thought it'd be
fine it'll be fine i'm used to this i
can go in a room and i'm usually very
different so it's absolutely fine went
in thought nothing of it and then she
she kind of didn't even pull me up to
her side and just said
i'm so sorry but brown hands don't sell
jewelry and i was like oh
okay that's amazing that she said that
out loud out loud in an entire room of
people uh yeah and and um since then
got married and i can wear that that's
great
um and um but you know since then i've
worked with swarovski loads and and and
i got to do my hand modelling so yeah
lady
you sort of think of other things to do
with your hands for that lady
yeah i would have been like oh does this
look good
yeah does this go with what you want to
sell
that was my exact that was my instagram
post that was my favorite it was my
exact instagram post it was like this
that's when i first wrote your husband i
saw it that day and was like i i like
you but i like him better and he's fine
olaf you can't talk like this
[Applause]
okay just go back to uh the hot priest
for a second twitter obviously went mad
for the hot priest and it was one scene
between the kneel scene
with that there was a gasp over there
[Laughter]
so what was it about that scene that
drove people so crazy
i don't really know i don't really ask
her
uh yeah i think uh it's quite strange
because uh the the it was just on phoebe
that scene yeah you know the camera was
just on her you actually never see uh
the priest in that scene so i did think
that there was a touch of the l
oh no
oh no you know it's it's definitely you
know transgressive and everything yes um
so uh yeah i think just the priest thing
does does it for people i don't know i
don't get it yeah i've been a confession
and yeah okay yeah yeah
you got it licked that's all i can say
everyone here just honestly there's just
a couple of treats these are mild these
treats between 7 hours and 15 days and
i'm still thinking about hot priest and
flea bag
i like this one i was at a catholic
church for a wedding today and honestly
it was too soon
this this woman went to a lot of trouble
for this one look at this she was so
happy with herself saw real life art
priests today they do exist and look it
does actually look a bit like
it looks like a vegan sub salad i see i
know and also it's bit weird wearing a
leather jacket right in front of a vegan
sandwich
and then this last woman she really went
for it people want a bridge appreciate
it people actually used to [__] hell
when that pre-said kneel my vagina
exploded the way a man has never quite
been able to achieve
that's rising very good
[Music]
you